hello let's talk about some God so
I don't like to make videos that revolve
around any form of drama I am actually
like physically repulsed by that like I
get physically ill when I see youtube
drama
I'm like oh god I started a YouTube
channel to talk about movies that's me I
like to talk about movies I like to make
movies to do something outside of that
it's always a little weird for me but to
me this doesn't really constitute as
drama this is about the legality of
paying someone or a number of people for
working for them and that's something
I'm going to talk about now if some of
you follow me on Twitter you will have
seen that I wrote yesterday that define
media owes me a considerable amount of
money they owe a lot of people money
this isn't just me so a background story
for you define media was an MCN a
multi-channel network some people might
wonder why would you join a network what
is the benefit of joining a network well
back when I joined a PHY there was a
considerable scare for youtubers that
Google Adsense might just drop you there
were a lot of people that had Adsense
that just got dropped for no reason it
was like a big epidemic for a while I
don't know if you guys remember that and
so a lot of people were like well a
network provides protection they're like
the middleman between you and YouTube or
in my case me and movie studios that
wanted to copyright claim every single
video I ever made I'm so glad I joined a
network to avoid copyright claims
because that's never been a problem ever
again
look I laugh because I had to laugh this
is a very serious situation and it's
actually very sad for a lot of people
but you gotta laugh sometimes you have
to you just gotta keep it real so I
joined if I because they promised that I
would become a managed partner which
YouTube this year has done away with
that
option but a managed partner was then
taken out of the copyright algorithm and
so the only way to give you a copyright
claim was if someone physically manually
watched your video and said nope we own
that claim you wouldn't get those bot
claims anymore if you were a managed
partner that was reserved for a select
few trusted youtubers who had proved
that they didn't break the law and so I
was a managed partner thanks to defy and
that definitely lessened the claims for
a while they eventually came back and I
always had to fight them myself and I
won every single time never lost a claim
from what I can remember there's been a
few times in the past before I was more
confident about fair use laws I'm just
trying to be very transparent I remember
a few times in the past where I was a
little afraid and I would just delete
the video like if it was an older review
but not anymore I know my now and I
know what the law is now so I joined to
fly under that pretense they also
promised me 100% of my Adsense earnings
they would take nothing but if they were
to bring me a sponsorship deal then I
would give them a percentage of that so
that's how they made money for me all
was okay for a while although the
company you know I'm still a little bit
leery about what all I can say in this
video because despite the fact that if
you've seen the news to find media has
shut down I'm just afraid about like any
type of repercussions on myself or my
wife or my family in a legal way based
off of any information I might divulge
to you so I have to be careful without
naming names or any specifics I saw a
lot of behind the scenes things at defy
that just seemed wishy-washy I never
witnessed anything illegal I never
witnessed anything in which someone
might immediately stand up and say
that's wrong I just saw a lot of
flakiness really you know just a lot of
people who weren't really
100% you know you know you have people
you meet in life and you can rely on
them and you know for a fact I can rely
on you you're gonna be there for me no
matter what if I'm in a rut you'll help
me and then you have people like defy
where you're like I hope you help me if
I need you and that's kind of how it was
for a while I stayed with them because
they were paying me regularly for a
while and things were going fine I was
getting a few sponsorships which helped
with the bills and stuff like that then
after I resigned with them for what
became the final year of defy media's
run things started getting worse the
copyright claims increased and they
called me and said hey were in a bind
can we take 10% of your earnings every
single month and despite the fact that I
really did not want to do that I agreed
so they got 10% of my earnings for a
while eventually they got a lot more
than that which we'll talk about in a
second I did not start my channel to
make money I've said this before but
I'll say it again I didn't make any
money on YouTube for like three years
and I still reviewed at least one movie
a week if anyone ever accuses me of
doing this for the money you're just
you're inaccurate I've enjoyed the fact
that I can now support myself doing this
just as anyone would love to support
themselves doing something they enjoy
but it was never about the money that
doesn't mean I'm just gonna sit here and
go okay company big la company take my
money enjoy it buy a yacht have fun pay
your bills with what I've earned
nevertheless I accepted the fact that
they wanted 10% of my earnings and I
moved on then throughout 2018 the
payments started to become increasingly
late
and when I say late I mean like two
weeks late and I would email them like
hey
I mean all of our bills come out on the
first of the month where's our check I
have a mortgage electric sewer gas water
you know all that I'm an adult it's
weird and they would say oh it's coming
next Friday that was like the quote
their favorite thing to say it'll be
there next Friday payments go out Friday
that Friday comes hey where is it Oh
it'll be in there by Monday you know
business day thing it's the weekend okay
I'll wait till Monday hey where is it oh
it'll be there by Friday son of a bitch
would it would go like that for the
majority of this year really and I never
went public about it because as I said I
hate talking about this kind of but
this is gone you know beyond your normal
drama and this is a little bit more
important I asked them when my contract
expired and that is February 28th 2019 I
would hear rumblings from other YouTube
networks they were trying to sign me on
they would email me and be like hey I'm
hearing things about defy you want to
join our network and I'm like I can't
break my contract
if you read the defy media contract it's
horrific aliy trapping it's extremely
stacked against you they had so many
options
legally against me if I did or said
anything wrong you know they basically
own my ass so I had to be really careful
so I couldn't leave even though I was
looking for other options then I heard
that the company was probably going to
shut their doors at the end of the year
and their next day a news article came
out about that that the company would be
closing at the end of the year and I
went all right well I better start
looking around for real like really
being careful the same time I was being
emailed by 2phi they were telling me
that my payments were coming for
September my September payment was
supposed to arrive at the end of October
or the very beginning of November they
kept saying
it'll come on Friday and then that
Friday happened and I got an email
saying look looks like we spoke too soon
it'll be next Friday and I said okay
I'll wait again this is the first week
in November now and then the very next
day right after that first news article
about them shutting at the end of the
year all employees of défi woke up
without a job if I just closed gone so
that's bad for all the employees that
work there some of the people there I
know and they're fine people stand-up
people despite working for a very
corrupt company and it's really bad for
all the channels that were still
partnered through them like mine because
that September Adsense and as well as
more than likely October Adsense two
months it's just where is it so my
entire Halloween special uh-huh all
those massive videos I worked on
everything I worked on in September and
October I will probably not receive a
dime for unless YouTube makes up some
sort of severance package but I mean
like that's that's it's hard because um
if defy media declares bankruptcy which
to my knowledge they have not yet I'm
not sure what the difference between
shuttering a company is and straight-up
bankruptcy but that money that I have
accrued over the past couple months of
making videos has gone somewhere and I
swear to God if it is gone to the CEOs
of this company paying off their debt
that's just not right that's criminal
that's criminal that's uh jail time to
be honest so it's a dirty situation and
it's very it's very frightening so yeah
I obviously have not seen Adsense for
September or
tober I also did two sponsorships for
them during that period in which I was
supposed to be paid through an ad agency
that was connected to the company that I
did a sponsorship for I've been in
contact with them and they're very
apologetic they've been very open about
it because the problem is defi was
supposed to receive a percentage of that
sponsorship payment as well and so now
this company that ad J the ad agency is
trying to figure out what the legality
is of just paying me when I'm earned
because they were also supposed to pay a
percentage of it to defi I just said to
them I was like look clear clear lead if
I didn't give a about my contract
you know just figure out what you what
you want to do so I'm waiting on that
that money was supposed to go to my
college tuition for the sponsor the
sponsorship money I was gonna put a dent
in my college tuition and now if I can
receive that it's probably just gonna
have to be stretched out to pay my bills
for the next like two or three months
until I can get a normal adsense check
it took a few days even for defi to
unlink my channel so even after they
closed for like a day or two I was still
earning someone money and if I here's
the problem YouTube's allowed me to be
in a pilot program this year I was one
of the few selected for this program
that allowed me to self rate the content
in my videos which means that there's a
smaller chance that my videos would get
demonetised because I can say well it's
still unlisted there's no excessive
profanity or violence or any of that and
then there's a greater chance of not
getting to monetize because of that that
means I can no longer bulk monetize my
videos so when defi finally unlinked
from me and then YouTube approved me for
partnership which they expedited because
it usually takes a month I emailed them
I was like it can't take a month please
approve me and they're like they will
get it done and they approved me for
partnership it was like
all over again flashbacks and then I I
click the select all videos box and I'm
like okay just monetize them all yeah I
can go to sleep now then I get this
notification that says I cannot bulk
monetize my videos because I'm in this
pilot program and I have to go to all
1,300 of my videos and monetize them
manually separately while answering
those questions about whether or not
they have profanity or sexual themes or
violence 1,300 times apparently so
that's just that's not gonna happen
what I mean what do you want to do just
spend like two weeks clicking boxes so I
emailed YouTube about that and they're
trying to find a workaround for it and
so that's that's the defy media
right now there's so much about this
that I want to talk about for one there
are so many other youtubers who are
completely out of money who maybe didn't
have any savings there's one person in
particular
Ian 40 I believe is his name who is
asking for donations because he can't
pay his rent and he was what defy mr.
Sunday movie is my buddy we were talking
privately before this before if I am
finally unlinked us both like what do
you do do you want to go public dude
what's the legality of going public I
talked to a lawyer who said like look
it's good to go public but be respectful
and that's that's fine I try to do that
anyway I'm even right now I'm trying to
see the humor in this situation which
there isn't much but if it wasn't for
patreon this month would have been
really tight because that's really
helped keep Sam and I afloat for the
first when all those bills came out you
know we were like hey where's the money
that we were going to put towards my
schooling and then some things that Sam
is working on and so I had a few people
asked me if they could give me donations
which I'm super flattered by please
don't worry about me it's okay there are
other people who need it more like Ian
14 you know
some of some other people need it more
than me so just you know don't worry
about me it's fine I just I guess I'm
going public about it and talking more
about it because I want networks out
there to know they can't do this to
people
you can't do this to people this isn't
just the thing is like we see so much
news nowadays through Twitter mostly and
it's like it goes in one ear out the
other
it's gone it's forgotten crazy atrocious
horrific things happen every day and
then there's something else horrific
happens the next day and you're like
okay well that's the next thing and we
forget about things this is actually
kind of gigantic a major YouTube company
just vanished and they oh people
potentially millions that's really bad
like I said that's possible jail time if
taken to court and it's it's just not
right I'm in post-production now on a
short film I worked on this year and
I've had to halt that I have a sound
mixer that I was going to pay to finish
the sound mix music is being composed
for it color correction and in some
visual effects shots and I have had to
basically just say I'm sorry can we wait
I have had to freeze a lot of things
like that because of defy and I was
trying to get it done so I could meet
that deadline for submission to the
Cleveland International Film Festival
because I would love if I could get it
into there because I'm from Ohio and
it'd be great like it'd be really
inspiring and I've had to just halt all
of that because I can't you know I had
to take the savings we have and just be
like okay I'm gonna have to wait a
second and make sure we can pay our
bills and it's really awful so that's
what's going on with defy as of right
now my adsense has returned to normal
but I'm still waiting for YouTube to get
back to me to monetize all of my other
1,300 videos I spent like an hour and I
got like a hundred of them monetized
just myself clicking like the most
recent ones
so hopefully YouTube gets back to me on
that I am looking for another Network
I'll figure it out or I might just stay
Adsense go old school because that could
be fun
totally completely independent like the
old pace anyway guys I just wanted to be
really upfront and transparent about
that it sucks for a lot of people I mean
Smosh was there Shane Dawson said some
about it on Twitter and you know
it's just a pile of awfulness that
hopefully gets itself worked out soon
but I guess my goal with this video is
to just make sure that networks don't do
this again to be a voice that allows
people to not only raise awareness about
what's going on with the five media and
what they did to so many other people
but also hopefully be of some solace to
other people who were in défi in the
same situation as me to let you guys
know that hey man you're not alone
and if we all band together we'll make
it through it and find a way out if I
receive any other updates about this
situation I'll probably post it on my
Twitter I talked about it on my patreon
podcast as well I let them know first
because honestly if it wasn't for them
this month would have been kind of scary
so thank you very much to the people who
have subscribed to my patreon that is
means the world so but like I said
there's other people who are in a worse
position who don't have as big of a
channel who don't have as big of a voice
who don't have like those contacts that
I have through my almost a decade now of
doing this and and those people need
help
Ian 40 being one of them check out his
Twitter he's got a donation page so guys
thank you so much for continuing to
watch and for continuing to support
going forth hopefully a situation like
this doesn't happen again for anybody
else who was involved if I I'm very
sorry for you having to deal with all of
this as more news comes out I'm
sure there will be more to come out
about defy and their shady dealings
behind the scenes it's it's not good but
thank you for everyone who has
stayed by my side one last thing just in
case you are perhaps considering well
yeah new media it's going nowhere it's a
sinking ship you shouldn't put your
faith in new media you know look what
happens I understand what you are saying
but there's no such thing as a
completely secure job I bet you the CEO
of blockbuster in the 80s and 90s
thought he was fine pretty sure the CEO
of Toys R Us for a while there was like
yeah it's all good
any job you can get fired from or laid
off any job trust me if you saw my
podcast preview where John Flickinger
and I talked about our jobs we had
before YouTube I've done the grind I
have done every normal job you could
think of in the book before doing this
Jim Carrey said something really amazing
in the documentary for the man on the
moon that's on Netflix he said he
learned by watching his father who could
have been a great comedian but settled
for a normal job because he thought that
normal job would be safe his father got
fired from that normal job so Jim Carrey
said I learned that you could compromise
at what you really want to do and still
fail so you might as well do what you
want to do that's my opinion on that
guys thank you so much as always for
watching I look forward to more reviews
very soon I will have videos coming I
just didn't want to make defy media any
other money I had to wait until my
channel was unlinked from them because
you know obviously for a good reason
thank you guys as always look forward to
more reviews very soon I'll see you soon
[Music]